and these are a lot poles
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey Dad
but I got done with my popsicle I'll
follow the stick down on the ground and
I'll come and help you Jackson and I are
setting up the new canvas tent we're
gonna have a family campfire dinner but
only Jax and I are gonna be camping out
tonight
if they need help call Tori
because I think you're the one that's
supposed to be helping me why did you
give him a popsicle when he was supposed
to be helping me I wanted a popsicle and
I knew if I got a popsicle I'd be in
trouble if I didn't get that one so
sorry I didn't think that one through
[Music]
oh see that oops can you hand that one
I love going camping as a kid with the
family when I was a kid me and my my dad
would take us camping far out in Oregon
Wilderness and uh it was always a fun
time
[Music]
one of my favorite things to do
now yeah extending that to Jackson I
hope he likes to go be outdoors
and this helps develop that love
I'm excited for when Josiah and Lila get
older and we can all do a big family
camp out all right bring me a yellow one
and go you did that fast God bless
whoever color coordinated these you did
great though baby we've already got the
roof oh here comes the hard part
hey Mom lock it notches because she
doesn't have long arms
I can't wait to camp out tonight from a
scale of one to ten how helpful is
Jackson
all right it's been helpful for a second
there is Daddy's so good Dad
[Music]
Paul Jackson
all right drop the ball
[Music]
good job Jackson very helpful even
though Jackson started off slow he came
through
wow
good job boys
are the girls invited
then we're sleeping inside that's the
boys
[Music]